et une et deux et trois tentatives de
braquages dans le tabac-presse de
patricia et fabrice en l'espace de
quatre ans le dernier en date c'était
hier soir à son comptoir patricia s'est
retrouvé avec un pistolet sous le nez et
à la caisse je suis resté figé
voilà en voyant j'ai peur et c'est mon
mari qui a comme il était là sur le côté
sur son tabouret qui a vu et j'ai
dégoupillé et j'ai aspergé ses l'aspergé
à distance parce que c'est une portée
assez assez importante grâce à
l'intervention de fabrice le braquage a
échoué le voleur a pris la fuite
un choc malgré tout pour le couple
obligé de défendre son commerce
quitte à se mettre en danger en a cinq
secondes qu'à 3 4 5 secondes pour pour
prendre une décision quoi donc on défend
sa croûte et quand cote quand on est
braquée comme ça et bien on n'a pas
envie peuvent pas forcément envie de
donner
je suis toujours pas décidé à donner de
façon du numéraire encaissent des
produits faciles à écouler des commerces
parfois isolés bref les bureaux de tabac
une proie pour les malfrats
il faudrait peut-être une présence
policière un peu plus importante bon
c'est difficile à l'heure actuelle
demandé à la police d'être partout parce
qu'elle est déjà bien bien occupé mais
je pense qu'il faudrait
réactiver quand même tout un tas de tout
un processus de rapprochement des
buralistes avec les forces de l'ordre
en attendant c'est fabrice qui a fait
régner l'ordre dans son établissement
pour protéger son tiroir-caisse avec sa
compagne le buraliste cherche désormais
à changer de métier